I'm a very conservative director I have
a lot of sort of ambition about my my
predecessors Geniuses that all of us
whether we know it or not are learning
from and upon whose shoulders we stand
and so I do a lot of looking back and a
lot of understanding what makes a good
story The Way Hollywood used to tell
good stories starting with silent movies
when there was there were just a few
subtitles to help you from time to time
where the visual arts were explosive and
and very direct it really LED you to an
emotional reaction and a huge climactic
ending without any words at all and then
how when films first found their voice
they all sounded like plays so my whole
love for this media comes from paying
attention to the past and respecting all
the movies that have been made over all
of these years and that's what I say to
film students when they say how do I get
a job and I say well it's easy to get a
job if you write because if they buy
your script buy enough of your scripts
you can insist on directing them but I
also say you need to look at the old
films